draw yourself a rough sketch looks like
this right let me show you how i use
this thing
okay by now i hope we know the basic
shape of cosine it's this valley looking
thing right
and thankfully for us this question just
goes in the standard domain the normal
domain we're used to
that's from naught to 2 pi so that's our
end point
you'll notice if i say that's 2 pi at
the end then i know where i am halfway
what's the halfway point
it's pi thank you so i'll just pop that
in right now what i'm asking
what this um what this equation up here
is asking is
where does that graph we just true that
valley looking thing when does it
intersect with zero that's the x axis
right and you can see it the two spots
here's one and here's the other one okay
with that
now even if you drew like a really quick
and dirty graph you can see
that's halfway this spot here is halfway
between naught
and pi so what is it it's pi on two and
then the other
one is halfway between pi
and two pi so what's that three pi on
two bam i've got two solutions the first
ones
right so i'm just going to got them down
pi on two or
three pi on two okay
so then i come across to the other side
i'm just going to change color for
reasons you'll see why in a second i'm
going to add
2 cos x to both sides any suggestions
what i should do next
should divide by 2 so that gives me cos
x equals
a half now one of the reasons why the
graph is so helpful is
the graph helps me answer this question
as well
what's the range of cosine where does it
go
one two negative one right so that's one
right there there's negative one down
there
so what this equation is asking is
that same graph that we just drew when
does it intersect with
a half where's a half it's whoopsie
daisy
it's uh it's here right do you agree
with that
if if one's up there then half is
halfway up right
so that's y equals a half so again you
can see
two intersection points i don't know
what they are yet but this is how i
immediately knew there would be four
solutions and if i got any different
number i knew i've done something wrong
okay so i'm looking for a solution
around here and a solution around here
now because i have spent decades working
on my exact values i already
know what those are okay but if you do
not if you do not immediately know what
those are then my suggestion is
to go back to your reference sheet okay
we're looking for cos x equals a half
cos x equals a half
we already said before cos is adjacent
or hypotenuse so i'm looking for an
adjacent on hypotenuse that's one
over two which angle is that you can see
right there 60 degrees do you agree
except i'm not going to write down 60
degrees because my question is in what
units
it's in radians so 60 degrees should be
this guy over here what is that in
radians
pi on 3. thank you very much and then
this guy over here because of the
symmetry
of all the tree graphs right it's 2 pi
take away pi on 3. do you agree with
that
you see how this distance here on the
left
is the same as this distance here on the
right so it's like 2 pi
and then you go backwards a bit
this is the beauty of the graphs right
no matter what you're solving for
if i arrived at this point over here but
instead it was cos x equals
negative a half i would just use the
same graph and draw this line down here
sorry that scale is terrible but you get
the idea right could you go through how
you got the zeros again
you're talking about these ones over
here yeah yep okay um let me finish
writing this blue working so that we've
got all four solutions and then i'll
come back
so therefore my solutions are x equals
what did we just say pi on three
or does anyone has anyone already worked
out what the last one is two pi
minus pi on three five pi on three thank
you
one final line is required which is you
got two solutions from one
equation two solutions from the other so
we should um tie that all up in a nice
neat bow
so i'm gonna write all four solutions pi
on two
three pi on two pi on three
and finally five pi
on three and i'm finished okay now just
to return to sarang's question
saran you were asking how did i get
these yeah and i get these
so i want you to think what does this
mean this
line it means this graph over here when
does it intersect with
this graph over here right now the graph
y equals 0 has a name
it's the x-axis so that's why i'm
finding
this point here that's one of the
x-intercepts and this point here
that's the other x-intercept is that
okay and so i understand that so like
you can't use uh all changes okay so
can you use all stations essential so
here's my diagram here right
i mean in some senses you can pi on 2
and 3.2 still exist on this diagram
but the problem is they are oops wrong
color they are
here there's pi on 2 going up like that
you see that's
i've rotated anti-clockwise from the
x-axis
um there's pound two its coordinates are
zero comma one no sorry did i say that
right
zero come one yeah it is zero comma one
right so i want the
x-coordinate is the cosine coordinate so
that's why i want it to be zero
the other one's over here there's three
pi on two so it's coordinates a zero
comma negative one
so you can see in both cases um you've
got cos x equals
zero but that's almost never how we
actually use the quadrance diagram we're
looking for which of the corners are we
in not
where the boundaries okay so it's that's
why it's just less well fit for that
purpose
question so if you do if you
sub into the calculator just um inverse
cosine of one on two
you get the first answer for x yep which
is three pi
oh which is pi on three yep so i is
there a way you can get
uh uh three pi over sorry five point
three
three pi on two uh or this one five five
this one over here you wanna get this
one out of your calculator
yeah sure so the short answer is your
calculator
will always tell you essentially the
first solution it can find
right it looks at from the origin
for cosine it will look from naught to
pi
and for sine it will look from negative
power 2 to pi on 2. so it's looking for
the closest one
to the origin essentially right for that
reason you'll get pi on three
out of it and if you try uh cos inverse
of zero
you'll get this solution right to get
the other one you've i got to think
about the graph or you have to think
about quadrants right it's why i wrote
down this
see that so we would call in this case
we'd call pi on three the base angle
and you have to know to find the other
one it's two pi
minus the base angle that'll give you
five pi
on three when we first
can you see that's two pi minus pi on
two right
do we have to think about quadrants
because here at the top it says zero
from zero to two pi
on the thing yep in the question right
here yeah yeah
so you're thinking in all four quadrants
there right it's already hstc yeah
exactly
okay i find the graph so helpful
i find that students who do not draw the
graph um i mean when i was walking
around i saw people who were missing
solutions or just had the wrong
solutions
can you see by the way like i can
already tell just by looking this graph
oh pi on three is just a bit before pi
on two
because it's a fraction right the graph
immediately tells you that the quadrants
are less good at debugging when you've
got an error that makes sense